[Música]
hola les damos la bienvenida a enlace
centroamérica desde costa rica cuando
usted dice que américa latina y el
caribe es el granero y los pulmones del
mundo costa rica es un ejemplo idóneo es
un país admirado por el cuidado de su
naturaleza y porque mantiene una
producción rica y variada en este
programa les contaremos sobre como la
agricultura una de las actividades
económicas más importantes del país es
fuente de empleo y favorece la seguridad
alimentaria también hablaremos sobre los
productos agrícolas costarricenses que
destacan a nivel mundial entre ellos la
piña y el banano y conoceremos sobre el
café de especialidad sumamente a
apetecido de posicionado
internacionalmente como uno de los
mejores les contaremos acerca de la
producción y el autoabastecimiento de
alimentos para el consumo de los
costarricenses
la agricultura genera el 12 por ciento
del total de empleos y representa el 47
por ciento del producto interno bruto
del país según el banco mundial a ello
hay que sumarle que en exportación de
bienes el sector agrícola es el segundo
en importancia con un aporte a la
economía del 4 3% del pib es decir más
de 3 mil millones de dólares lo cual
representa un 20 por ciento del total de
las exportaciones de costa rica- el
producto estrella es la piña
costarricense siendo el país el mayor
exportador de esta fruta en todo el
mundo la nación centroamericana también
se ubica como la tercera exportadora
mundial de banano
costa rica además exporta raíces y
tubérculos como la yuca sus frutas
tropicales y exóticas como melón papaya
sandía mango pitahaya mora uva pero
también sus plantas flores y follajes
viajan a diversos destinos a pesar de la
pandemia las exportaciones de productos
agrícolas aumentaron un 6% entre 2020 y
2021 costa rica siguió colocándolos en
estados unidos como mercado prioritario
la unión europea y centroamérica
la meta es llevarlos más lejos
indudablemente los mercados son muy
exigentes el sector empresarial se ha
venido preparando con certificaciones
que es lo que está buscando el cliente
como el cliente desea que su producto
sea presentado y muchas veces
encontramos fallas del mercado
fallo del mercado es como podemos cerrar
brechas fallas del mercado son temas de
logística y nos ha pasado muchísimo
tenemos una piña exquisita pero tenemos
un gran reto de cómo lo colocamos en por
qué por ejemplo en china
otro de los productos agrícolas insignes
de costa rica es el café el llamado
grano de oro transformó la economía del
país en el siglo 19 cuando en 1820 fue
exportado por primera vez hacia panamá
hoy día se obtienen 326 millones de
dólares por concepto de envíos a todas
partes del mundo de café de la especie
arábica una de calidad superior
en tarrasa una de las principales son
las cafetaleras del país la familia
castro se dedica a producir café de
especialidad desde hace 10 años en el
micro beneficio juana chute durante esta
época del año los trabajadores se
dedican a la fertilización y aplicación
del abono de cada planta
del grano a la taza hay todo un largo y
cuidadoso proceso que ha venido
encareciéndose debido a la guerra en
ucrania que ha aumentado los precios de
algunos insumos
y no solamente precios sino la escasez
realmente que hay es bastante difícil lo
que son los precios de fertilizantes y
demás aparte de que están súper caros
están súper difícil de conseguir
entonces actualmente creo que es un
nuestro principal veto además ya
hablando en temas de exportación hay una
limitante en contenedores también
entonces las exportaciones están
bastante atrasadas el buen café
costarricense se toma afuera pero
también dentro del país la organización
mundial de café ha colocado el consumo
de café de costa rica como el segundo de
latinoamérica sólo detrás de brasil
pero costa rica exporta productos
agrícolas porque tiene la capacidad de
auto abastecer a cerca del 80% del
consumo nacional de frutas verduras y
hortalizas un aspecto clave para la
sostenibilidad y seguridad alimentaria
de la población sobre todo en momentos
de crisis mundiales
yo creo que en pandemia la gente lo vio
y lo valoro creo que lo vivimos en los
meses en que todas las actividades casi
que se cerraban bueno acá soy costa rica
nos impactó mucho el turismo los hoteles
y todo pero los agricultores seguimos
trabajando
tuvimos la bendición de que es campo
abierto de que era menos este la
posibilidad de enfermarse y yo creo que
nuestro país no tuvo ninguna escasez de
alimento hasta el momento curiosamente
los ingredientes del plato típico
llamado pinto o gallo pinto que son el
arroz y el frijol son en buena medida
importados de países vecinos costa rica
cosecha el 65% del consumo total de
arroz de sus habitantes mientras que en
frijol solamente produce el 20 por
ciento de lo que come su población hay
épocas que en países otros países
producen a menos costo entonces de ahí
es más fácil importarlo porque nuestro
agricultor no llega al rendimiento en
otras épocas del año en las épocas
ideales y producimos sembramos un área
importante depende de las épocas pero no
nos alcanza para todo
un país verde que ha logrado importantes
hitos como ser el primero en
latinoamérica que logró revertir la
deforestación y aumentar su cobertura
boscosa debe manejar un balance entre
esta conservación y su producción
agraria sus productores lo saben y
aprovechan incentivos estatales en torno
a la protección ambiental como los pagos
por servicios ambientales a la vez piden
también políticas públicas que apoyen al
agricultor a mantener esta producción
nacional que garantiza la alimentación
de los costarricenses hasta aquí con
este enlace centroamérica sobre costa
rica gracias por habernos acompañado
para ver nuestros programas síganos por
france 24 y france24 puntocom